[Music]
so welcome to another episode of the
addie hour
today i'm honored to be able to host
co-founder of march for our lives david
hogg
and today we're going to be jumping into
a conversation really talking about
activism
self-care and ending gun violence now i
know for those of you in the audience a
lot of you are probably familiar with
david you're familiar with his work and
his
efforts i think today it will be nice to
really peel back
a little bit and talk about some of the
things that he's been involved in some
of his goals but also about him as a
person and some of the things that he's
really trying to elevate
um in terms of really making sure that
the work that others are doing on the
ground a lot of ways is also highlighted
as well so really excited to jump into
this conversation
obviously david is someone who is thrust
into activism following the tragic and
unfortunate shooting at his high school
in parkland florida in 2018
and from that event he and his
classmates have really vowed to be
game changers and change makers in a lot
of ways
and he's resolved that no other person
no other young person should have to
experience the tragic impact of violence
of gun violence in particular so as i
mentioned he's the co-founder of march
for our lives they've been involved in
lots of different initiatives over the
years
just to highlight a few the march they
had in washington dc where he spoke to
an estimated 800 000 protesters
he and his sister lauren are also
authors they co-authored never again
which became a new york times
best-selling book
they also contributed to the book
glimmer of hope how tragedy sparked a
movement
and they've been involved in lots of
different efforts over the years touring
across the country really meeting
families and individuals who've had
losses at the hands of gun violence and
also educating themselves about ways to
really make an impact
david's also someone who has a pretty
large social media following
and he really uses his platform to
promote civic engagement
activism and voting so again just
grateful to have david here on the addie
hour episode today david thanks so much
for taking the time to join us
yeah thanks for having me on of course
so again
you know a lot of people know about you
maybe not know a lot
about you in terms of per on the
personal level but one of the things i
really like to do
on this program too is always just to
check in with folks um i think it's
important to remind people that you're
also a student
so you know in the middle of all this
work that you're doing you've also been
taking classes or coming to the end of
the semester
so i just wanted to start out and see
how things are with you these days in
the midst of everything that's going on
in the world you know as you're wrapping
up the semester
um just in your daily life how are you
doing these days
yeah i would say i'm pretty good um just
trying to
figure out um
i don't know it's kind of weird because
when you take time off of school or work
i think a lot of people have this
feeling where it's like
you don't have things to be stressed out
about anymore
but you still have the stress for some
reason you know so
i've been dealing with that um and i've
just been thinking a lot more about what
i want to do
in the future um just because i'm i'm
now halfway through
through my my uh you know four years of
college
and uh thinking about different
um different opportunities and stuff
internships and things to do
even though i i really honestly i wish i
could just you know
uh take time off and like not do
anything for a minute because it's uh
i think our my generation especially but
pretty much americans in general have it
uh an arguably unhealthy obsession with
like
doing as much as possible and don't
really value spending time with
friends and family as much as i think we
should um because we think in a very
almost like hyper-capitalistic manner
that
can uh you know really kind of hurt a
lot of our friendships relationships and
you know
uh our family relationships overall um
although i think a lot of us have been
able to spend more time
this year with our with our families and
everything for some of us perhaps too
much
um but uh you know i i think i'm doing
i'm doing pretty good overall
just uh trying to be more accepting of
not necessarily knowing what i'm gonna
do in the future even though i know i
know it'll be something vaguely
political or
communications or whatever um you know
being
being accept more accepting of the
unknown and kind of embracing it
and taking care of myself while i'm
doing that right right
well i appreciate your honesty and that
and i think that's a that's really
helped in a lot of ways too
but i think it's good that you you know
you're being honest with yourself and
also highlighting the tension
between all the work that needs to be
done but then also
knowing that you know it's still good to
slow down spend time with family and
friends but
there's not always an easy answer so i
think you know just even the fact that
you're verbalizing this i think for a
lot of us sometimes it's easy like you
said not to verbalize
it and just go kind of a thousand miles
an hour and not even take that time to
pull back
so i mean yeah no too you all have been
i mean i mean i think part of it is just
because you all have been so
it isn't baked in the culture like you
said but all the important work you all
have been doing
over the last three years so i just you
know just to kind of pull back a little
bit what's that been like
would you say for last three years being
david hogg i know that sounds like a uh
like a cheesy question but i really just
wanted to kind of get a sense or a
capturing of
what that journey has been like for you
um i mean it's certainly had its ups and
it's down
i would say that it's been really
amazing to see how
my friends and i are able to take an
idea like doing a march on washington or
talking about youth voting and really
trying to help turn it into reality
although we were by no means the only
people
that talked about youth voting for
example um
it's been incredible to see the
achievements we've had over the even the
past three years with one of the highest
youth quarter turnouts in 2018
of any you know non-presidential midterm
um
and really the highest youth voter
turnout in american history in 2020
it's pretty remarkable um
but i also so i think those are some of
the the high high
high points i think some of the lower
ones though are
as i kind of talked about earlier that
unhealthy obsession like hyper
capitalistic obsession with productivity
and like that's
that being the only thing that matters
um
paired with the trauma and survivor's
guilt of you know going through shooting
um and and talking to all these people
that have have experienced gun violence
on a daily basis literally probably tens
of thousands of people at this point um
the pairing of those two things is a
really dangerous combination that i've
seen
um hurt a lot of people that i know that
have worked in
um what i would call the peace advocacy
space
um because the work that we do is very
important
but sometimes because it is so important
we lose sight of how important we are
and the importance of taking care of
ourselves in this because of that guilt
because of that ptsd and that trauma
the trauma-driven response um i think
i've certainly had my own
um you know challenges with that not
you know not just because of like
notoriety or attention or whatever
much of which you know quite frankly is
because parkland is a disproportionate
you know a predominantly white community
that's more affluent than the average
community um but it's also because
uh i share a lot of that
a lot of that unhealthy obsession with
productivity and i for a long the
longest time i just
i really looked at the work that we were
doing like a campaign
you know i thought in 2018 we're just
gonna work 36 hours a day basically
you know every single day and not stop
for anything
i mean literally work oftentimes until
we got physically you know
sick to the point that we couldn't work
anymore which happened multiple times to
me and i
i know happened to others that we worked
with um
but it's really taken me broadening that
view and realizing that
my self-care and hanging out with
friends and talking to people isn't
something you feel guilty about
um it's something that's a necessity
it's part of my productivity
um because this isn't it's not like a
campaign where it's a you know a sprint
you know you have november third or
whatever date it is
right that you're going to finish by um
we don't know when gun violence is going
to end it's more
it's much more accustomed to you know an
ultra marathon where we don't know the
ultimate destination and there's a lot
of wrong paths we can go down
so we really have to pace ourselves and
be even prepared to pass on the baton to
the next generation
although i hope that's not necessary
right um
so it's been a lot over the past three
years it felt like a lifetime
um so much travel so many you know
people that i've met
so many experiences um
and i really had to challenge myself to
figure out
how to prioritize myself and putting
kind of putting on my oxygen mask first
before i can help anyone else and it's
it's difficult when we have this
obsession
with constant achievement and constantly
doing
more and more and more and more you know
being obsessed with productivity instead
of
um realizing the importance of and it
sounds super cliche and i i mean
i kind of hate the term but like taking
care of yourself you know because we
hear it all the time but i never really
understood what that meant until
you know the past year or two um but
because of that you know i've really
been able to take my care of myself and
take a step back and think about what
how do i want to enter the space instead
of what are all the holes that i need to
fill in
yeah so that's kind of what the past
three years have been like you know i
actually struggled a lot with um ptsd
not just from the shooting but
actually from activism um in
you know the threats in the harassment
in even the how hard we were working at
times you know
like getting four hours of sleep you
know often times
you know every day for a month or two is
not it's not healthy especially when
you're a younger person you need a lot
of sleep um
and and then you have to go in front of
people and talk and then you have to go
on the
you know the news and stuff and you're
concerned that you're you know
are you taking up too much space you
want to uplift you know how do you
uplift people properly but not in a
tokenistic manner but how do you like
still highlight the issues that's going
on
yeah um and
you know luckily because you know going
to therapy for basically the past year
and a half i've i've really been able to
start focusing much more on taking care
of myself and consistently
you know checking my vases every day of
like it seems ridiculous but just eating
you know drinking getting enough sleep
and focusing on those basic core things
until i can really start people that you
know uh on top of that foundation to
become more productive but in a healthy
and healthy manner yeah
yeah i think that's so important i mean
there's i think there's a lot of
maturity there too and growth along the
way
and that you know not saying that you
weren't mature early on too but just
even the way that you kind of
characterized like you were going a
thousand miles an hour at the beginning
then you're realizing where you need to
pull back where you need to have that
self-care
but you know i imagine that's still not
easy because in some ways i think that's
what beats a cycle because you know the
less sleep
the more work you do the more outcome
and the more output you can see
so i'm curious like how did you move
along that because in some ways it's
almost like you had to sacrifice
some of the work to be able to take care
of yourself and you talked about having
that long-term trajectory
i imagine that's still attention because
it's like well i'm not doing this work
i'm pulling back
so x y and z is not getting done so how
have you
reconciled that in your mind i think the
main way i've reconciled it is realizing
that
i you know i think because we have a
very individualistic culture we have a
tendency to get very self-absorbed in
the work that we do and think that we're
the only person doing the work
um and that applies to all of us
honestly because you know we're all the
stars of our own reality tv shows
in some sense you know in our mind um
i think what it took me realizing was it
it was truly effectively delegating
and working to hire people you know that
were actually
qualified to do this work had experience
doing this work in the non-profit space
um and organizing stuff to help do the
work
uh within march fertilizer you know the
organization has basically grown
you know over like basically eight times
you know over the past uh two years in
terms of like our total number of staff
because we were
woefully understaffed and had a severe
lack of experience honestly
with a lot of the work that we were
doing um and it's still youth led but we
have people that have more experience
you know
helping execute the plans that young
people ultimately come up with in the
first place
um so that's been the most effective
thing is like
hiring other people to do the work that
i didn't necessarily need to be doing
myself but i just found myself doing a
lot of the time
um and then just preoccupying myself
with school
you know because it's as you can imagine
going going to college
and uh traveling every weekend
and going on like it's just you know i
kind of had to
realize that there's some sacrifices
involved in order for me to prioritize
really what's best for my future and
that's going to college instead of just
you know um necessarily doing a ton of
work every day in this in this field
that
in some ways is also just exhausting you
know it's a
activism a lot of the time is a it's a
really thankless job
um and it's
uh it's difficult because you can you
can believe that even if you do achieve
these things that somehow it's going to
like
make up for that lack of self-care but
it doesn't it really doesn't
um so yeah it's it's been difficult
making those decisions but you kind of
have to learn how to say no
a lot of the time even though it's hard
um and it feels like you're
you know it almost feels like because
we're told so often about how important
it is to take every opportunity
it kind of feels like you're cutting off
your right arm for lack of a better word
yeah
um but you have to realize that you know
even if it does feel that way
ultimately you have to be able to you
know survive and
focus on what's really important and in
my case that's school yeah
um and it's also the work that march 4
lives does that doesn't get on the news
focusing on mutual aid focusing on
you know the different aspects of racial
and economic uh
justice that plays into ending gun
violence and stopping people from
wanting to pick up a gun in the first
place instead of just talking about how
they get the gun
you know it's a it's a we have to have a
holistic solution here that we talk
about
and those conversations unfortunately
are things that are great to fit in
sound bites are great to put on the news
um for a lot of people because they they
don't want to talk about the lack of
resources
that causes a community to you know that
results in violence
and historic and systemic injustice uh
but
that's the work that we're doing and
it's uh it hasn't been an easy
transition but i've just realized you
know i have to
take care of myself and focus on what's
ahead with school and uh
yeah been working on a couple cool
projects at school too i worked on our
our
there's a public opinion polling project
that i worked on this semester for use
so yeah it was cool yeah i mean a lot of
ways it sounds like you're just you're
letting yourself ride that tension too
it's right i mean because there's so
much work that has to be done
you know i mean even as i'm listening to
you talking i'm sure it was probably
hits you too like
i mean that's a herculean amount of work
that you're talking about and that's
not something that any would be would be
able to do if they're spread too thin
at the same time certainly no one can do
themselves yeah yeah
i mean would you say that you all have
as a group have people bought into this
idea of self-care or has it been
certain pockets of people like how's
that i'm just thinking about you know
i'm imagining what the vibe was like
when you all started and how much energy
there must have been as you all were
touring across the country
but i'm curious if that this shift is
kind of predicated
marginalized or do you think it's in
pockets i think it's in pockets i
i think it's more like i think a lot of
the time especially young people that
were involved in the beginning
myself included but especially for some
of the other people that weren't as
privileged as me to have like
the power of being like not only like
being a guy but also being like a white
straight guy
in the first place like inherently it's
gonna be a lot easier for me to exist in
these spaces than a lot of
you know other co-founders that were
women or non-binary or were
you know lgbtq whatever um
and for a lot of them they they
understandably just got exhausted and
weren't accepting of a space that you
know um
wasn't you know was just really
difficult for them to function in
because
you know young people are important with
hr experience
you know unfortunately and uh in a
youth-led organization i'll say the uh
the the reason why march march for our
lives has been successful is because it
is youth led
but it's also that very same youth-led
energy that can also end the
organization because it's
you know it's the combination of a lot
of energy and
kind of ad-hocracy with paired with a
lack of experience to be honest can be
really really damaging so a lot of a lot
of the co-founders have
you know um taken a step back which i
think is fine you know i think we see
that throughout these movements there's
there are people that take years off at
times and
step back in and you know honestly even
if some of the co-founders don't
ever want to do this work again they've
done more than 99.9 percent of people
will ever do in their lives around this
issue so i
you know i'm forever thankful for that
and i can't i can't blame them
because ultimately you know i want them
alive um that's what it comes down to
because this work is really
it's really hard um for these uh
young people so i think a lot of them
were either like myself were forced to
learn about self-care
um by to use a metaphor kind of like
you know you can tell someone to not put
their their hand on a hot stove
um a lot of times but sometimes it takes
getting burned to really realize the
importance of not doing that
and i think that may be the case not i i
don't mean to generalize but i think it
is the case with a lot of young people
especially traumatized young people that
care so much understandably about this
issue
um but yeah so a lot of the co-founders
have taken a step back
to focus on the arts focus on uh theater
focus on college which is totally valid
and i'm never gonna
i'm never gonna you know blame them for
that but i think
as an organization we've gotten a lot
better at focusing on that self-care
aspect
we do a lot more workshops and you know
trainings around it and stuff now
um but unfortunately when it is young
people there is some element
of needing to learn it the hard way at
least in my case because i
i can't tell you how many times i was
told to you know make sure you're taking
care of yourself and i i didn't
understand
yeah i always heard that but i didn't
understand what that looked like for me
until i really sat down
and started to kind of get reconnected
with my
my emotions and my experiences and stuff
because i think
especially with guys uh i know that i
had a tendency in the beginning to just
shut out all the emotions and
trauma secondhand trauma that i was you
know hearing about every day of people
you know having their loved ones shot
having their
even their pets shot in front of them
you know just horrible stuff
um and just like kind of like blocking
it out was i thought was the best way of
dealing with it but it actually just
piles up you know and
i actually found myself i thought i
thought the
ptsd and the trauma and stuff from
activism from
obviously the shooting and stuff was
which is something that would make me
sad and that's how i would know but what
i didn't realize is it it just made me
numb i didn't feel anything
for the longest time um which was really
concerning you know it got to the point
where like i
every conversation i had was about gun
violence and i
because i i was talking so little to any
of my friends about anything else
because the work just became our life
yeah um and
what it took for me was really sitting
down and journaling every day to get
back in touch with my emotions
and like what i to process what i had
gone through in the past year going to
therapy and stuff
um to understand that those emotions are
you know are things that i have to cope
with
as anyone else does and it's not just
something you can just block out so
that's been a lot of my journey around
the uh the self-care aspect and
the co-founders as well and and other
students but you know i'd be like if i
said it was uh
if i said it was easy and there weren't
people that you know um
you know are hurt not necessarily by any
fault of their own but just by
you know we're trying to do the work of
a government here essentially
because our government is not doing this
work and that's not what we're supposed
to do we're supposed to have elected of
you know we're supposed to be college
students
or high school students we have elected
officials that are supposed to represent
us for a reason and it's exactly so we
shouldn't have to do this
yeah and that's that's so important i
mean you know i mean you've hit on so
many important
pieces there too but i mean i think
again just though it seems like you
really got into a good place of just
realizing a lot of these things i mean
kind of the self-reflection even as
you're talking about the journaling
that you're all doing more work than you
should be doing and just all the weight
that comes with that because even as you
were talking about you know all the
families that you've interacted with
across the country like immediately my
mind was going to like i mean all those
conversations are witty
and in some ways i feel like you must
have even if you didn't know been
carrying all that
on you too because those stories you
hear them over and over again they're
going to penetrate at some point
i mean it seems like a lot of ways
you're able to kind of channel that
energy into the
increased activism then still you have
your own story you have all these
stories that you're carrying
with you and so really having a place to
process that i think is really
important it sounds like it's been kind
of a weekly daily process for you as of
late just making sure that you have
the space for that which i think is
critical but not always easy to um
acknowledge in the in the heat of the
moment in the sense when you're in the
middle of the work so
yeah i i mean i think it goes
it's also uh it's so important to deal
with that self-care aspect because i
i've seen so many times how in activism
because it is it it i would be lying you
know if i said it wasn't traumatizing
work for a lot of young people including
myself like
you know getting followed by people with
ar-15s getting screened out by them
having your house swatted you know death
threats
that i get but also a lot of kids that
work in the organization
and in the gun violence prevention
movement and people too in general again
um you know that trauma and that
exhaustion can end up turning
us on each other because we start to
think the reason why we're not being
successful is because of people that
we're working with
when in reality it's because this you
know no
you know you can say activism isn't easy
or social change isn't easy but it is
really
really hard and it may not be because of
it's
it may not necessarily be because of
anybody's fault that you work with
but you can start to turn on each other
when you're not taking care of
yourselves
which i think is a major problem that
not just you know
the the peace advocacy space has but
also
a problem that social movements have in
general because the work that we do
really is
incredibly important um but when we're
not taking care of ourselves we can have
a tendency to turn on each other and get
really negative
and act horribly towards each other and
if you don't select times
you know on a regular basis to really
sit down and talk those things out
it piles up and it really starts hurting
people yeah yeah
i think that's so important you're all
paying attention to that so i mean even
you know all the things that you all
have been through
i mean just in general and people have
gone through that as you know i mean it
has effect
it has an effect on people's day-to-day
lives just in terms
of like you know school work in general
can they still focus as well then you
add on
all the activism work that you're doing
which has a whole another heightened
level of
importance and tension and and just
weight to it and you put all that
together so i think yeah that's so
important
that's been at the forefront forefront
recently in other ways
um you know i was thinking back to one
of the interviews you and your sister
did too you know
one of the things you talked about
reminding me of that just when you all
were talking about how
the activism was your therapy in a sense
and it seems like what you've been
talking about is ways that you're able
to kind of channel that and use that as
a way to cope do you think that was
effective and helpful in some ways i
mean you kind of talked about the ways
where some things were ignored but
now you didn't pay as much attention
necessarily to some of the self-carers
you really
could have yeah but what what would you
say are some of the positives
of of what you're doing and the activism
and how that
affected you all as people i mean i
actually think sometimes that like
massive marches and demonstrations even
if not you know
um directly politically impactful or
something like that you know
uh i think it can actually be really
beneficial in some ways because people
realize they're not alone and i think
that's been one of the biggest benefits
that we've seen a lot of social
movements um from
you know feminist movements historically
speaking to civil rights
um to to peace to anti-war movements is
in some ways they're almost like
massive you know it it's certainly not
like you know certified as group therapy
but in some ways it's kind of like a
massive venting session that
i think actually can be really helpful
for people i think
the issue comes when those individuals
continue to focus so much on that and
sacrifice stuff to try to end the things
that are causing this trauma that they
end up throwing away the things that
they love
and the people that they love not
throwing them away throwing them away is
too hard of a word but
not prioritizing them just as much as
the work you know
um and that ends up making them feel
really resentful you know
towards the movement towards the people
that they work with because they feel
like they've sacrificed so much and
there's been so little progress
which you know honestly um there's been
a lot of progress in terms of the
historical perspective
in gun violence prevention but um
on the skill that we needed at it's been
very little unfortunately
um but i think it actually the activism
in some ways
done properly can be a form of therapy
but done
done in a way that causes harm or done
in a way that where you're not taking
care of yourself can be a
you know a form of trauma
when you're throwing away the things
that you love and just working on it
every single
day and you have you know there's no end
in sight of when it's going to stop
right um so yeah that that would be my
main
yeah my main way of thinking about it
yeah i think that's a really good point
i mean the the
group's area three therapy piece in
particular i mean i think there's a
there's a lot to that because there's
that
you know common lived experience that
you all had right you can support each
other in and
talking to someone who understands who
understands it
yeah and there's a lot of power in that
you know because we feel like
we're surrounded you know when you're
around 800 000 people even if not all of
them have been affected by gun violence
a lot of them have been
um you know like like at the march for
example
um those people see each other and they
see that they're not alone
and i actually think there's a huge
amount of value in that
especially with like the power of the
nra and the
people that choose to try to advocate
for the rights of inanimate objects over
human beings
um you know they're so loud
and they have such you know strong
connection to each other that
the people that are actually affected
mostly by those by those actions that
want people and kids to be protected not
weapons like an ar-15
control alone even though we're actually
in the majority if you do call
you know the country in general um
and that's that solidarity and
friendship piece and community peace
is extremely powerful because it's that
community
that enables social movements i believe
in the long term
to succeed because at the core at the
core of
social movement power in the core of
political power isn't politics
at all it's culture it's music it's
storytelling
and it's only in those community spaces
when we're around each other
that we're able to like you know show
love and appreciation for each other
and care for each other even as
unfortunately no actions taken or even
you know retroactive actions taken um
we're able to be there uh kind of as the
the bedrock and endurance that is
necessary
for the sustainability of the movement
but when that when that community is
only working
solely on the issue itself and not
really hanging out
and talking with each other it's that's
when things you know come in and that's
actually one thing i realized in some
research
that i did this semester that wasn't
necessarily very scientific but it was
just for
a history class of mine you know i was
interviewing
a different civil rights activists that
uh went to harvard and worked on like
the freedom rides
for example and uh
one of them talked about how uh
i won't say his name for for privacy
reasons but one of them
um talked about how when he initially it
was like i think it was like 1963 or
something like that
he went down to uh the south to work on
the freedom rides and he he was meeting
up with like some young people from the
student online coordinating committee
and everything
and he walked in the room as a sophomore
at harvard i think
and uh he was expecting a ton of
students to be strategizing on a
chalkboard and like drawing all this
stuff out talking about policy and
everything
but he walked in and you know these
young civil rights activists
you know from all around the south we're
actually having a preach off seeing who
could imitate mlk the best
you know and dancing and playing guitar
and and singing together
and one thing he told me is like you
know how how could you see that and not
want to be part of that
right i think it's that community aspect
hanging out with each other that
music that really builds successful
social movements in the long run
because ultimately you know leaders in
social movements can have their own
impacts in
in different ways but the real power in
those isn't just
it's in the culture and it's in the
community because
um you know it's uh as movements are
ones where everyone are leaders in the
first place
you know where everybody's able to lead
themselves and take care of each other
and it's
when we're not doing that when we're not
having fun it's not sustainable so
that's been a big focus
of myself in it um the organization over
the past year is figuring out how can
it's difficult with covid but how can we
celebrate our wins how can we
you know take time to hang out and do
things not related to incredibly
exhausting and traumatized work like
trying to stop people from getting shot
yeah that's so important i mean the
research backs us up too you know in
terms of the psychology research that's
been done looking at the power of
community even in terms of neuroscience
research
looking at what being a community does
to the brain and how it helps with just
moving through stressors and resilience
i think i mean
right everything you're saying is
spot-on in a lot of ways how would you
how would you say you're cultivating
that because it seems like there's two
pieces there there's both kind of
self-care of the daily self-care but
then also making sure there's the
community self-care
making sure that those are are ingrained
yeah so i think one thing that we are
trying to do kind of
is trying to develop some kind of system
to deal with the
the um inevitable grievances that come
up between organizers
and leaders um on a you know an annual
basis where we just talk it out
you know we talk about and move on
you know um but it's also
the way that i practice it personally is
um
i i just call up friends randomly that
i've worked with um
which you know some people don't like
being called or whatever but you know
i'll text them or
i just like talking to them and stuff
and i asked them you know i
i basically at some points you know i
check in with them and i just talk to
them casually
but really you know it's to it's a good
way of checking myself to make sure i'm
taking care of myself but it's also
it's a good way of having accountability
for making sure other people are taking
care of themselves as well so i think
if we look at the history of the civil
rights movement unfortunately because of
understandably the incredible amount of
trauma and stuff behind it there's a lot
of people
um we hear a lot about like the
successes of the leaders and stuff and
different
everyday people have participated what
we don't hear a lot about is you know
the people that you know ended up um
abusing various like substances and
stuff because of the trauma
and not being able to do with it and
stuff and you know um
i don't know how much of that you can
when it's that level of trauma i don't
know how much of that you can actually
just deal with through community
um but i think that's something that
we're trying to develop in the
organization but
just personally you know i i just call
friends randomly a lot of the time and
check in with them and
i'm like hey so what are you doing to
take care of yourself you know what are
you doing that you love
um that you enjoy and
you know how are you making sure that
you're not under water basically and
taking on too much stuff because we need
you to be here
we need people to be here for decades to
come possibly and
not just the next two years but the next
20 or even longer
hopefully not but you know we need to be
prepared for that so
i found that that's a good way of
checking with people because
i think there's a bad tendency that i i
still have
but not nearly as bad as i used to and i
know a lot of other people have had
in the organization in the past where
we'd only talk to each other in moments
of crisis or when we needed to like
mobilize
and when you have that i think there
comes to be an association with
each other of really negative feelings
and grievances
yeah um if you're only mobilizing after
you know
say another shooting happens or
something like that it's not healthy
and by focusing on talking to each other
in uh
non-crisis times it's a good way of
realizing that we're on the same side
here
right and it helps reduce those like
interpersonal conflicts and make sure
that we're taking care of ourselves
which further helps reduce those
interpersonal conflicts
yeah um and it's just a good way of
forming relationships because ultimately
you know
at that core political hours i talked
about the past two i think it's i think
it's culture
but it's also that community and the
fabric like the
the strings that make up that community
and weaves it together are relationships
and they're not relationships that are
just made because
you're only talking about work right
they're made because you understand
what's going on with each other
you know what's going on with each
other's families what's going on with
each other's you know
significant others or whatever and going
on personally and you're there to
support them
even if it's not work related because
the best i think those are the best type
of uh
uh activists you know community
relationships are the ones where
they're not at their core they're not
just around okay we need to do x thing
right it's around
actually knowing what's going on with
each other and understanding each why we
do this work
and each other's motives and the
challenges that each of us uniquely face
yeah that's so true because then you
have that foundation too like you said
that's not just focused on
the mobilizing of the trauma of this
kind of built throughout that and that
again the research would back would back
that up too there's so many important
so many important pieces there i'm
curious if you feel like there's enough
resources in place too because i mean
one of the you know i don't do trauma or
specifically but i know one of the
things that comes up quite a bit
is making sure that people really know
how to help other people walk through
that
because you get a lot of instances where
people don't know how to handle that
so they have good intentions but they
actually just end up re-traumatizing
people
i mean you mean right you you know we
talked about that before we got it just
in terms of somehow somehow some of the
interviews that you've done and how it
kind of gets back into that same thing
over and over again
so i wonder if you all have even thought
about that in terms of the movement
like do you feel like there are more
resources and obviously that's a
challenge if resources within
but are there more resources that should
be in place to help people actually
process
that trauma as they're engaged in the
work so that it's not
you know going into a place that's just
making it that much more difficult even
with good intentions but unintentionally
right yeah i mean i i think that we
certainly have more resources than we
did in the past
but it's not nearly enough um
i'm i'm just talking about the movement
as a whole but i mean which includes
march for our lives
um i think one of the difficulties is
that um we're so focused on spending the
money like on the work that needs to be
done
uh it's it can seem hard for us to
justify like
you know if we need to pay for a
therapist you know or like some kind of
like
community counselor or something um even
though
in my opinion like resources are
severely lacking but honestly the
biggest obstacle besides the nra to us
actually being successful i would say is
our trauma
and the divisions that it creates and
it's hard to justify it can be hard to
justify to a fun you know
to donors or people that just give a
small amount or whatever um
you know spending spending a couple
couple thousand dollars for example and
like
helping reduce like community trauma and
like all these things that sound very
big but really are important
um and in managing better relationships
and how to do those trainings
instead of spending that money on
registering you know a couple hundred
new voters or a couple thousand new
voters or whatever right
even though the only reason why we the
the overall return on
investment if you know if that's really
what we're talking about here
is significantly more if we're able to
do more work and get more volunteers and
develop a stronger community
if we're able to deal successfully with
that trauma um
but i would say you know that's one of
the difficult things is uh honestly if i
could i
i would uh if we had the money to do it
and
people were more accepting of like
understanding the importance of that
um i i would love to hire way more you
know hr people and like
um not just hr but like uh
i don't know what term to come up with
that doesn't sound incredibly vague and
like
bs but like i guess like people that
really help manage community wellness
and like yeah developing proper
protocols
between like how to train people like
especially in the past
year you know since george floyd and
everything like
talking you know it's difficult when
there's kids from all different
communities of all different races that
oftentimes you know have never really
worked together in a social justice
manner they might have gone to school
together and stuff but like um
you know the dynamics of racial identity
and trauma in the united states and
talking about it is uh something a lot
of
to be completely honest you know just
white kids do not understand
at all you know i it's something that
i'm still learning about if i'm being
completely honest and trying to
i'm always trying to get better at it
but it's uh it's not something we're
born knowing especially and we
certainly don't learn it from society or
the media um
so yeah i don't think we have
necessarily at all enough resources to
deal with that trauma unfortunately
because it's hard to justify
yeah um but it's needed you know and we
have done some things around it you know
we try to do
we try to have like occasion you know
somewhat you know uh
we try to give people time off have
retreats and we try to be really
affirming of when people need to
you know go on vacation and really
celebrate that because like
this work is hard it's really hard and
our issue is not that people don't want
to do the work it's that they want to do
too much work
yep yeah so i mean yeah in a lot of ways
i mean you're talking about a cultural
shift too
because if some of those those resources
are needed and i agree with you that
makes things better in the long run but
it doesn't look
as shiny if you're trying to you know
trying to raise money it doesn't right i
mean it doesn't look like a
as much of an investment because you
can't see that outcome right away
you can see what happens when it's not
addressed but right
yeah yeah you know it's not
unfortunately the work a lot of the work
that needs to be done in the
organization and
in in the social justice space is not
you know to end gun violence
or you know uh address the things that
plan to gun violence like racial justice
or environmental injustice or
economic injustice or not things that
necessarily get on the news super easily
um for example march this year committed
to a
uh we have a half million dollar
commitment to like grants and focus on
mutual aid you know providing food
clothing whatever
whatever communities need and going
specifically to the community the black
and brown communities that are most
impacted by gun violence
and asking you know asking them how we
can be supportive to the
you know of the community organizations
like life camp who i'm wearing the shirt
of right now
um doing the work on the ground stopping
kids from shooting each other you know
or
everyday people from shooting each other
instead of going to them and saying this
is what we're going to do for you we're
going to throw
you know ten thousand dollars at you and
you're just gonna be happy and like
we did our job we're equitable or
whatever we're gonna really ask because
we understand we don't
i don't know what goes on in for example
jamaica queens where this this
shirt of life camp that i've worked with
i don't know what goes on there you know
erica ford who's been doing this work
for 20 years
in jamaica queens and is stopping kids
from shooting each other
every day um she knows what needs to be
done right so we ask people like her
what can we do to be supportive but um
even though there's that big commitment
which is a significant part of our
budget we're not
like the nra we don't have 100 million
dollar budget or whatever a year
at all um we you know
we we get by but it's it's still nothing
in comparison to that
even though there's that commitment and
the work that comes out of it
um it doesn't get on the news you know
so it's hard because like
we know that that's the work that needs
to be done to actually be
to to help advance the movement forward
but it's also
difficult because we know that a lot of
that money in comparison to spending on
something like
um you know a big event or something
it's not going to go on the news but we
know that that's the work that needs to
be done i think that's actually a really
big problem with the non-profit
industrial complex
if you know if i'm being completely
honest is that we have a system of
incentives
that incentivize people to do things
that get on the news even if they're not
necessarily effective
right i can't tell you the number of
times i've seen organizations spend six
even seven figures on things that could
have been massively impactful
for extremely under-resourced community
organizations
um and had a huge impact but they choose
instead to spend on something that's
going to get on cnn
or whatever um even though it's not
going to have that much of an impact
you know in comparison to where that
money actually really could go so right
it's um you know it's difficult because
we get questions like oh what is march
for our lives doing
it's like well we're focusing on these
mutual aid programs we're focusing on
talking about
what we call armed supremacy right like
the role of guns in white supremacists
like circles and actions and the
enforcement of white supremacy in the
united states
you know we're talking about mental
health but not in a way that's like
not not in a way where it's like let's
talk about the mental health of the
shooter at my high school
and why he decided to do that and talk
about that only because he's a white kid
right um and you know we tend to
stereotype
white mass shooters is mentally ill
because we don't want to talk about the
fact that they're
a lot of the time not always but a
significant amount of the time it's
simply
or not i can't say simply but uh it's in
large part if not entirely because
they're
a racist um you know the shooter at my
high school was racist and anti-semitic
he was known to have drawn things like
swastikas on stuff and
you know um i i don't see that meant
that racism
and anti-semitism as a mental illness
um but it's difficult because we want to
talk about mental health in regards to
the two-thirds of gun deaths that are
suicides
they don't get on the news right right
that's really what needs to be addressed
if we're gonna talk about addressing
total gun deaths we should be talking
two-thirds of the time
if not more about gun suicide but
because
the mental health conversation is only
around who a mass shooter is
i cannot tell you i i've had
conversations before with kids that said
like
they they were depressed so they went
through the school counselor and their
school counselor
put them on a list saying that they were
a possible mass shooter
because they were depressed and they
were worried about hurting themselves
right
that is the effect that the media is
having on these conversations yeah and
it's so hard because
you know we can't those conversations
around
armed supremacy around mental health but
around suicide prevention
and around you know mutual aid and
racial justice are not easy things to
fit in a sound bite like exactly
you know universal background checks
which yes can have an impact but
ultimately
you know isn't it for a lot of cities
that have stronger gun laws although
there's certainly a lack of federal ones
a lot of these guns that that get there
quite frankly you know
um get there illegally because there's
there's a lack of like
federal guidance around interstate gun
trafficking that could actually prevent
it you know if you
if you can't if it's extremely hard to
get a gun in chicago or you know it's
not necessarily as hard as it could be
but it's still hard nonetheless
you can just drive 30 minutes to indiana
and get a gun and come back
or some guy can go and buy 50 guns and
sell them out of the back of this truck
legally a lot of the time you know on
the south or west side and
and have them go out that way but what
we need to address is you know why are
these people
why do people on the southern west side
feel they need to pick up a gun in the
first place it's because
they don't have resources you know
parkland has significantly weaker gun
laws than chicago or
any more than many other cities in the
country we don't have shootings on a
daily basis
and it's not because it's not because we
don't
it's not because we we have the most
police officer or the most
you know stringent gun laws it's because
we have the most resources
and having those conversations are not
that those nuances are
extremely hard to get across in a tv
news interview
right it doesn't fit into the neatly
packaged trauma industrial
media complex that commodifies these
mass shootings
where they have graphics like it's a
like it's some kind of baseball game or
something
where it's like this is how many people
you know die
this is how it compares to other mass
shootings and things like that without
any regard to the fact that
most people that are going to die today
from gun violence are
self-inflicted gunshot wounds they are
unintentional shootings
and their everyday acts of you know gun
violence of interpersonal gun violence
and domestic violence
right that's what needs to get on the
news but doesn't it so it's yeah
it's difficult because our what we need
to do is over here
you know uh it it's in one corner and we
know what we need to do
but what actually enables people to get
a good like the nonprofit cultural
complex to get a return on investment so
they can continue doing the work
might be in a completely different space
and there's plenty of people that do
that and then we get people asking well
what are we doing
and the answer is we're doing more work
than we ever have yeah and we're in
the best place the organization in my
opinion has ever been in terms of
sustainability
but we're focusing on things that the
news doesn't typically like to cover
yeah so i mean you're doing the real
work but it's not getting out there and
like you said i mean with sound bites so
much of the truth gets lost too
i mean especially around the mental
health conversations i mean all the
evidence shows that
those struggling with mental health are
much more likely to be victims of gun
violence and perpetrators
exactly somehow that continues to get
lost in the conversation
those issues around funding are why we
need more people to contribute
you know like we'll tell you about the
work that we do it's just you're not
going to see it on cnn
even though it's way more important than
the work that does get on cnn yeah
yeah so you know on that line's like
what do you see as your role because i
mean there's that
again there's that tension which i think
is just a theme of the work that you're
doing because it's so
one it's such important work and it's
such a huge problem that attention is
going to be right on the face but how do
you balance
between what you're doing on the ground
that you know is making an effect
making a difference versus what's
getting the air time
in a sense not that the air time is
important but right in some ways the air
time could help
galvanize right the work that's being
done so i mean if you all have those
conversations if you're trying to
you know wrestle with that yeah i mean
it's difficult i think what we try to do
is we try to
we're trying to make the organization
work more uh faithful
instead of faceless if that makes sense
um and we're trying to show the other
leaders in the organization that may not
be from parkland but
nonetheless i would consider almost like
co-founders of different marches you
know around the country
yeah um one of them is like a board
member of mine
a fellow board member youth board member
of mine who just graduated college and
is now a truman scholar named
a movement he's done a ton of work in
gunman's prevention in salt lake city
um and you know we we try to get him on
the news but it's difficult when
news one wants to celebrate they want to
put us in a box of like
mainly white parkland students and just
that's it when in reality
we realize in order to make this
movement you know our contribution to
the movement because we're by no means
the movement but make our contribution
to the movement successful and as
impactful as it can be
that it it has to go beyond the wall you
know the border of parkland
it has to be all-encompassing in the
united states and it's difficult because
it's harder to tell a story that way
because there's so many different
communities
right and you're trying there's so many
different solutions that
that have to be talked about but we
realize that that's really the only work
that can be done the other thing that i
do
is that when i'm doing interviews is um
you know
for example yesterday i was on msnbc and
they're like you know how are you david
all that stuff and like i care about
that answer is i'm not great
honestly i don't think anyone that's
gone through an instance of gun violence
is ever really
great um ever again um
but what i you know what i always try to
do is i try to redirect it towards
people like erica
that you know in jamaica queens that
have been doing this work for
basically over 20 years at this point
and are having a
massive impact um you know it's talking
about people like pastor mike that work
with
groups like live free and faith in
action out in oakland california
um that are doing the real work on the
ground with cities and violence
interrupters
um to redirect the conversation towards
them and i also see
you know because i'm able to get into a
lot of these rooms because of you know
my my profile or you know the fact that
i'm i'm a white guy
um and these rooms even though the
majority of people that are affected by
gun violence tend to be
like you know black and brown um you
know i see my role as helping up open
open not i hate this idea of a table
because there shouldn't be a table to
begin with you know because that's like
a whole power structure right but
what i see it as is trying to trying to
like
kind of step back and put people in my
place
you know or exp i guess help expand the
table in some way or i
i've lost track of the metaphor by this
point but you know what i mean like yeah
i'm trying i'm trying to use my position
to basically bring people like erica a
lot of the time
into meetings to deal with these people
you know about like
not being inclusive not you know doing
these things properly
it works you know because of meetings
that i've had before other organizations
i'm our other coalition groups um that
were almost
not entirely white but were you know
almost entirely white
yeah um you know if we're in new york
city and we're having a giant meeting
30 stories up in some building but i
know erica's and jamaica queen's doing
this work
and she's not in that room and no one
like erica is in that room that's a
problem
right so um i see it as helping to
i don't know i don't like the power of
the dynamic of like shine a light on
um on other communities but i'm trying
to
expand the spotlight to include the
community the communities have been
doing this work for
decades that have to organize not
because they want to because
it's for their survival it's for their
literal survival that they do activism
is not optional
for many people from the majority of
real activists that are out there it is
not optional they have to do it for the
community their own survival
or their community's survival um
so that's what i see my role as is
trying to you know acknowledge the
amount of power
that i have in in this position that
quite frankly much of which
you know is because the work that i've
done but also
a large amount of it is because i'm a
white guy um and recognizing that
the responsibility that that power
carries to acknowledge that
and expand it to you know in or not
expand it but
just you know highlight the work that's
been doing for and show respect to the
people that have been doing the work for
decades
before me and with that power also use
it to challenge
other parts of the disproportionately
white you know
peace at you know the national gun
violence prevention organizations
to challenge them to actually focus on
things that aren't just around
gun control although it's needed but
talk about violence intervention
programs and because of things like that
um you know erica ford and uh pastor
mike and
others you know were at the white house
in the rose garden
and biden upped his commitment from you
know
in our initial kind of peace plan that
we came up with i think we had like a we
demanded like a billion dollars
you know over several years or something
like two uh
violence intervention programs and
because of the work that
uh the community justice action fund
amber goodwin and others have been doing
around that and in that space and
because i believe because the part of
march for our lives
challenging these other organizations by
highlighting the work that these orgs
have been doing for
way before any of us were here yeah i'm
biting up this commitment to five
billion dollars a year
or not five billion dollars a year um to
five billion dollars over like eight
years
to these programs that aren't policing
based but are public health based
you know and can actually help um
communities in the first place by
providing trauma services and reducing
retaliation and resources
um that's so neat and that's why i see
my role is helping to challenge that
dynamic
um i'm by no means perfect i i still
[ __ ] up a lot
um but you know i i try to do the best
that i can
and acknowledge when i do pick up and
you know continue to work through it
yeah i mean i think that's that's great
i mean it's a holistic approach in a lot
of ways because
i mean i hate i keep using the word
tension but i feel like it's all there
because i mean some you know you know
you've done the work like that carries
weight but then you also know there's
privilege
which you didn't yeah there's a lot of
it there's a lot yeah so i mean you're
bringing those together you're still
making sure that people who have been
doing the work on the ground
are acknowledged and so i think that's
in a lot of ways what you're talking
about is walking alongside them
and i think that's important too um i
really see it as like i'm here
being the one to kind of save you from
your whatever x y and z
but i'm learning from you i'm gonna walk
through it with you right and come
alongside you i'm gonna bring you where
i am
yeah yeah and that's that's really the
approach that i try to take you know
when i when i worked with erica in the
past for example i
i just happened to be in new york for
you know different meetings and stuff
and i was like you know i have a couple
days off or whatever i'm gonna spend it
working with you and i'm like
so you know erica see me as an intern
you know like you want water i i'm here
to learn i'm just here to observe you
want water i'll get you water want
coffee i'll get you coffee
like you you need literally use me in
whatever way you want i just want to
observe
and learn from truly the best so i don't
even see it as walking alongside them i
see it as walking
behind them and i you know and let
seeing them lead and learning from
you know the different paths that
they've taken of how i can be supportive
in that in the first place
and uh highlight the work that they're
doing
for lack of a better word all these
words you know there's such a power
dynamic and they're so loaded
you know like uplift you know uh
show this trying the spotlight because
it like it there's
such a i don't i don't like the power
dynamic that's within that vernacular
because it's not it's not the power
dynamic that like is productive to this
conversation because it comes from like
a white saviorist place
like that vernacular you know is a not
only white savior's place but also a
white supremacist
place in the first place that implies a
sense of entitlement
and a belief that you know more about
how to
what to do for someone's community than
uh
the people that actually live in that
community know what to do right um
so it's difficult to talk about but um
honestly i i just try to lead with
humility and ask
ask uh you know how i can be supportive
as much as possible while acknowledging
that you know i do screw up
from time to time you know uh but trying
to learn from those things and unders
and be forgiving with myself too which
is hard yeah especially with the kind of
culture that we have on twitter and
social media that is
not forgiving a lot of the time which
again is completely
unrealistic as you know as i'm sure you
know especially
yeah i mean this goes back to the first
part of conversation with everything
that you've gone through already in
everything
that you're doing perfection is always
unrealistic but when you put all those
pieces together and
i mean we talked about this too just
about the trauma it's just not even a
healthy place to start so i know we're
still back right now this
there's a huge cultural shift that we
need to have in a lot of ways
um and you know in some ways i think
hopefully covert has helped with that
granite cover has not been a good thing
by any stretch of the imagination
but i think in some ways it helps people
realize how a lot
more of us react under stress and
uncertainty
and knowing that okay there needs to be
some room for forgiveness when things
get switched in and when people are in
the middle of work
after trauma you need to have that grace
and forgiveness to be able to move
through things and say okay are things
really getting addressed
or are you putting these standards on
people to go a thousand miles an hour
and hit unrealistic goals and then if
they have any little falter then you
just come down
hard when you're not even driving
through it yourself
right and i i mean my thing is too that
you know if if the movement can't be if
we're too pure for ourselves
how are we ever going to have other
people join in
right when like the way that we learn a
lot of the time is these mistakes
unfortunately exactly um it doesn't mean
that there's no accountability there
should be
yeah but there needs to be you know a
demand not just for accountability but
true growth
and learning um because that's the only
way that these things become successful
i think it actually plays into the um
a bigger thing around how you know
although yes our government has a much
bigger role to play
in uh in ending gun violence and passing
these laws and helping fund these
programs
there's also a cultural role that we
need to have in a re-evaluation of
why are we as a country so
you know obsessed with
machines made to kill people that that's
what they are right
um why do we romanticize violence and
you know stigmatize
you know so many other things that are
not like that
um you know and
it's uh yeah i i think it goes into not
just a
a cultural aspect because the way i see
ending gun violence is it's like
i think about a third of it is like the
gun laws i think a third of it is like
different things about how do we stop
people from wanting guns in the first
place but another third is the cultural
aspect
that we have to we have to acknowledge
the fact that although our government is
corrupt in a number of
in in many ways ultimately our
government
is a product of not all of us because of
rampant voter suppression
but many of us and it is a reflection of
our values as a society
yeah as a society we need to either
reaffirm or
change some of what we truly
reprioritize what we truly do value
um you know in order to do that and i
think that that comes down to a whole
conversation too around justice
and i truly believe that if we want to
end gun
gun violence we need to acknowledge that
gun violence is a symptom of injustice
if we don't address that injustice if we
can't make a
a an unjust country we'll never be a
peace country
a peaceful country ever yeah and we have
to talk about that those resources
and the systemic injustice that causes
this gun violence in the first place
even though it's not easy to fit into a
sound bite
it really is the only way we're ever
going to end this in the first place
yeah
that's so well said so important and
you're right i mean it's not easy
i think that's part of the challenge
that you all are trying to deal with
head on
so i mean i'm encouraged to hear about
the organization you know still thriving
a lot of ways even outside of the public
eye
in a sense and some of the structures
are put in place especially around the
delegation
especially around the self-care because
again i think that's important for the
life for the organization and like you
also the life of the community
um and the life of communities that are
doing this work i would imagine you know
those you've mentioned in the news for
20 plus years
those pieces have to be in place in some
say perfect the community piece and
the self-care otherwise you know with
everything that
there and we're already into is just not
not going to be sustainable so
definitely i mean that's a it's a big
focus of the organization too
um part of the reason why that you know
the media's lacking stuff is that
we're we realize as i said in the past
previously too that you know stuff it
gets on cnn isn't necessarily what ends
this but it's uh
you know we're focused on on doing more
and saying less
because ultimately like you know the
time that we spend talking is time that
we could be spending registering voters
it's not that we could be spending you
know helping raise money for community
organizations and building coalitions
instead of competing against other
non-profits and stuff which i think is a
horrible
um product of the hyper-capitalistic
non-profit industrial complex that
has been developed around treating
symptoms like gun violence instead of
addressing causes
of gun violence in the first place um
but you know it's uh it's all the more
reason why we need people
to help fund us because you know we're
not getting we we may not be getting on
cnn but we're registering voters we're
doing we're doing the real work
yeah um and we've seen the product for
that for the past couple years
yeah that's really encouraging to hear
and i appreciate you know us you know
taking us through the journey too
even in terms of from the beginning
where you are now um one thing i do want
to do before we wrap up though is just
in terms of you know folks who might be
listening
who are saying okay you know i want to
know more about either what's going on
in my community or how i can help with
some of these more national
um initiatives like where where would
you direct people in terms of really
making an impactful difference and not
just going for the uh
the shine factor or technician or
anything else like that
yeah i mean i think the best thing that
you could probably do in general where
there's a lot of resources available
is just going to the march for our lives
website it's just march for our lives
like march for our lives.com
um and there you can register to vote if
you're not um but you can also text our
954 954 text code um that can let you
know about local events
elections and things like that and that
our chapters and and coalitions are
working on in your area
um and you can see a lot of the work
that march is doing that may not
necessarily be getting on cnn but is you
know
um even more important than the stuff
that gets on the news
so yeah that's that's really what i
would say in um
you know just try to do as much as you
can at minimum try to make it voting if
you have the privilege because
unfortunately voting is not
a right in this country i would argue
for many people that have been
incarcerated
um but uh if you have that ability to
vote
please do so at the minimum and if you
if you're able to do more
you know try to do more get involved
with you know um
local community organizations just look
up like gun violence prevention
organization or whatever in your city if
you're in new york
life camp's a great one that i would
suggest um they're in jamaica queens
there's also
uh save our streets and bronc in the
bronx
there's live free and uh
um there's lib free and
faith in action in oakland in the san
francisco area
um there's uh in los
angeles i'm trying to think of what it's
called um
i forget there's a number of
organizations there's a lot of
organizations that just work in la too
that you can look up
um yeah just you know try to figure out
how to get involved and even
even it's just in a small manner just do
it consistently you know even if it's
just voting try to vote in every
election
um even if it's just you know trying to
volunteer
help out in any way um or working on a
campaign
of a of a candidate that you're you know
really runs on gun violence prevention
we need more people to do that because
we don't we have the disadvantage of not
having several hundred million dollars
like the nra does
but we have the advantage of having way
more people that support us
you know in general but we need those
people to be much more out there
because the nra is a extremely loud but
effective
uh they're they're an extremely they're
small but extremely loud and effective
minority
um and if we could just figure out how
to get a small percentage of our country
multiplies around this issue
we'd easily end it in 10 years or less
way less
yeah well i appreciate you sharing all
those resources and all that that great
advice i mean there's so many different
opportunities for people to really
jump in and do the work that needs to be
done and the work has already been do
done
in a lot of ways so all right well
appreciate you coming on
coming on the addie hour and taking us
through and we covered a lot of ground
so
a lot of important round but really
appreciate kind of hearing the journey
and what you have uh
going for and continue to wish you the
best in this important work especially
the work that's not you know not getting
their play i mean i think that's where
right where the real you know the real
work is being done in a lot of ways but
hopefully
you know with some of these pieces
things will continue to get governed yes
glad you're taking care of yourself too
i mean yeah well thanks for having me on
i appreciate it
yeah it's been great
[Music]
you